und ich bin jetzt beim Bundestag dabei
und Eindruck bin ich als Grundwehrdiener
im gebirgskampfzentrum in Zweifel und in
den nächsten Monaten nehme ich ein
bisschen auf der Reise mit und sorgen
wir sind Bundesheer also
[Musik]
ersten
Ausrüstung
die Ausbildungen losgegangen
[Musik]
jo was hat sie in den letzten Wochen
äußerst so verändert ich bin einfach
viel erfahren
nicht nur die Sachen die was man lernt
beim Bundesheer sondern mal circa andere
Sachen mit was wir das ist
[Musik]
ganz viel Leid Fehler die was mit dir
schlafen und doch
mit der Uniform ausfahren und es ist
schon bisschen aber ich glaube da
allgemeine Dinge
und man wird alles respektiert und immer
[Musik]
entschieden ich glaube in Österreich
gehört
Gelöbnisse auf die Republik rollig ist
es schon
was was man nicht jeden Tag macht die
man sagen es war schon ein bisschen
ist es glaube ich super gelungen und es
ist Spaß gehen und jetzt einmal richtig
offiziell beim Bundesamt
so jetzt bin ich angelobt
und ich freue mich schon drauf und nicht
in die nächsten Wochen für unsere Seiten
vom Bundesamt kommen
[Musik]